so how does the spinning tube trick work
well a lot of you identify that the tube
is rotating about its long axis and it's
also rotating horizontally about its
middle but how does that allow us to see
one symbol and not the other
well let's say we press on the X if you
press down on the X it'll actually be
spinning backwards with respect to the
motion of the tube in its horizontal
rotation so when the X turns to face
upwards it will actually be spinning
backwards with the tube while the tube
is moving forwards so the velocity of
the X will be reduced by its spin in the
backwards direction on the other hand
the O is spinning in the same direction
as the tube is moving which means that
the O will move across your field of
view much faster and therefore it'll be
much more difficult to see I want to say
a big thank you for all of those who
submitted a video response I really
really enjoyed watching your work okay
this entire gravity hmm don't hate to be
smart he's got a smoother surface and I
like that oh this is my favorite part in
that way both the red all right it would
spin the old spin back George me so the
side touching the ground travels less
distance than the part not touching the
ground causing it to spin slightly
slower the outer part takes longer to do
what 72 hours that's amazing
there's a dedication I would also like
to thank everyone who posted in the
comments their suggestions I think
rumble 45 was the first one to post a
correct solution so well done to you and
this just shows me that we need some
more complicated physics puzzles for you
guys to try to solve so I'll see what I
can do and I'll post one up shortly
until then keep spinning those tubes